a lot of people want to get on the
phones today at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and we
will do that right now let's go to our
caller from the 7 8 6 area code who's
calling today from 7 8 6 hi hello can
you hear me yeah I can't who's this hi
my name is Lily mom from mommy
great what's going on quick one question
um I've been seeing a lot of news in
regards to the issues going on in
California where after the tax cuts that
happen in the past
they sort of affected the way California
is going on for example there's a lot of
people moving out more like more
Millennials so I was kind of wondering
to ask you from is there so there a
current method that California can use
to sustain itself but the current tax
issues that going on were there I'm not
sure I understand you're saying people
there you're saying California cut taxes
and now people are moving out because of
that
no I'm sorry I mean like you know the
tax cut the the federal tax cut that
this protect us we can we passed right
okay and that's causing people to leave
California correct and you know there's
some way yeah why are they leaving
California because of the federal tax
program as I recall I believe has
something to do with the salt taxes okay
let me explain that's that that's good
all right so what what we're talking
about here is the following the Trump
tax plan put in place a limit of $10,000
federally in terms of how much you can
deduct for state and local taxes as well
as real estate taxes so if you live in a
state with higher property values where
your property tax will be higher and a
state income tax particularly a higher
state income tax you are much more
likely to hit that $10,000 limit meaning
if you have $15,000 in salt you can only
deduct 10 of it meaning you now have
$5,000 you used to be able to deduct
that you no longer can California would
be an example at least in some parts of
California where that would apply now I
haven't seen
data that people are moving out because
of it I mean we only just now taxes
haven't even taxes aren't even due yet
for 2018 but you're saying people have
already moved out because of it also be
fair I just recently watched this video
from Fox Business where they're skating
it's sort of like a thing to think it's
a trend that's been going on in
California where like people are just
moving out when businesses are leaving
and then they get back on example like
Toyota I think going to like Texas and
business local businessman I think is
giving okay but hold on so we got a
break let's break this down a little bit
first of all if Fox Business is saying
it I would analyze it really really
closely the salt limit wouldn't push
Toyota to leave the salt limit affects
people's personal income tax so Toyota
wouldn't make decisions based on the
salt limit and all right I've had is
long predating the Trump tax plan I
think I think we just you know we got to
look at exactly what assertion they're
making but this is not all totally
coherent I guess they met with I'm sorry
I'm not speaking correctly enough I
guess I'm trying to say that for Mike
Napoli the song is that people is
pushing people to leave or and as well
as that what Fox Business is a theme is
that because of the tax how taxes work
over there people are you know just
leaving and going to places like Texas
in Porter yep we'll listen I mean I
there there will often be migrations of
people from high cost of living to low
cost of living areas and then things
will kind of rebound back high cost of
living areas cost a lot for a reason
which is that they're generally speaking
desirable and people want to be there so
if Fox is making that assertion they've
got to prove that it's because of the
tax rate or whatever
otherwise it's it's a correlation
without any real causation so it's
pretty specious reasoning and on that
basis I mean I couldn't say what
California needs to do because I don't
even think we've really actually
identified what the what the problem is
for sure okay all right I appreciate the
call thank you very much great to hear
from you